Five,
four, three, two, one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Andrew Houck: We're running a
rocket lab for the Freshman
Scholars Institute.
So the purpose of the
lab is to give students
a familiarity with
physics and math,
and give them a hands-on design
and engineering experience
where they can explore
these concepts.
So for the past
four weeks in lab,
they've been building
a number of things.
They've been building
these circuit
boards, which are essentially
the equivalent of a satellite.
The whole project is to launch
a rocket up into the air,
and to track the
flight of the rocket.
And so this, like sort
of any NASA launch,
is like the satellite--
it's a bunch of electronics.
And what this does
is it measures
the acceleration of the
rocket 128 times a second.
CURTIS MERRILL: I'm hoping to
do mechanical and aerospace
engineering.
So this is right up my alley.
To get into kind of a
college environment,
with a small group
of kids, and just
really be able to learn how to
adapt to a Princeton learning
situation in a very low-stress
environment, where there's
a lot of resources
able to help you.
So it's been absolutely
perfect for me
in just learning how to adjust
to college, to Princeton
specifically.
[MUSIC PLAYING]